un autobus transportant une équipe de
rock et de la saskatchewan a été
impliqué dans un grave accident dans
l'autocar il y avait 29 personnes et
tous ceux qui étaient à l'intérieur sont
soit morts ou ont été blessés
ça touche beaucoup de monde du sport
parce que dans ce port et beaucoup de
déplacements souvent notre but sur but
et oui
ça les dommages sont impressionnants on
parle de toitures arrachées de voitures
qui ont été renversés ces gens qui ont
besoin d'un toit
ce soir parce que le leur s'est envolé
lors des dernières élections avaient été
extrêmement serrée parce que le portrait
politique risque fort de changer donc
une soirée qui s'annonce très
intéressante
radio canada prévoit que le prochain
gouvernement de la caq sera majoritaire
nomme marqué l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
sidiki 3h30 ce matin
vous me parlez nous de votre expérience
qui a un excellent terreau appuierait le
choix quand même assez bien détaillés
qui s'est produit à toronto du nord du
centre-ville n'est tout juste d'arriver
sur place sur les lieux de cet incident
là où une camionnette blanche a foncé
blessés fauché des piétons ou dizaine en
tout le chauffeur a été arrêté
vous voyez tout juste derrière moi un
petit peu vers le sud
une présence policière très importante
on l'appelle la route de la méditerranée
[Musique]
un trajet emprunté depuis deux ans par
plus de 500 migrants de la libye ou la
tunisie vers l'italie
[Musique]
au lendemain du sauvetage réussi on en
apprend davantage sur la délicate
opération et sur les dangers imminents
tic et et les enfants et leur entraîneur
de soccer tech les choses avaient plutôt
light du réalisateur jean marc vallée a
remporté quatre prix à la 75e cérémonie
des golden globes
[Musique]
et
à
il est
oui
[Musique]
m